Peter Drucker famously said if you want
if I want to know what you believe I
could ask you what you believe and maybe
I'll believe your answer but show me
your calendar and your bank statement
and then I'll really know what's going
on and when we tried to calculate was
the altered state economy how much time
and money do people spend trying to
change the channel on normal waking
consciousness and unlock these
heightened states of information we did
a global calculation we looked
everywhere from illicit to illicit drugs
which is an obvious place to start but
we also looked at things like
pornography and social media where the
neurochemical your reward you're getting
from these experiences is very similar
to the neurochemical reward you're
getting in these states at the heart of
a lot of this is the chemical dopamine
dopamine is a focusing drug as a
performance-enhancing drug and it's a
pleasure drug it is also incredibly
incredibly incredibly addictive porn
addiction is very much about dopamine
right if you think about porn from an
evolutionary point of view our sex drive
is about procreation we're not getting
any of that from porn we're not watching
porn for what it makes us feel sexually
we're watching porn for what it does to
us mentally it changes our state of
consciousness it gets us high and it's
the dopamine that is getting us height
it's knocking out us out of normal
waking consciousness and it's lifting us
up to a heightened state unfortunately
porn on demand tends to be very very
addictive and people get in into a
downstream cycle with it we see the same
thing with social media right simon
Sinek famously says if you know you wake
up in the morning and you're you know
checking your phone before you're saying
hello to your spouse that's an addictive
behavior and it's dopamine that is
driving that addiction so what happens
with social media is Robert Sapolsky you
did the foundational research on this at
Stanford calls it the magic of maybe
when you look at your phone and maybe
there's a text there and maybe there's
not and you don't know when it shows up
that high you get that's dopamine it's
the
maybe maybe it'll be there maybe it
won't when it shows up you get a 400%
spike in dopamine that is roughly the
same amount of dopamine as you're
getting from cocaine it's slightly less
than an extremely addictive drug like
cocaine and that's what's happening and
it's interesting because if you think
about things like things that you know
routinely produce a lot of dopamine
alcohol for example there's a drinking
age right we have a drinking aid the
alcohol release is a whole lot of
dopamine it makes you feel really really
good we say okay you can have that but
you've gotta wait you've got to be 21
years old we don't do that with online
pornography we might want to do with
online pornography we don't do that with
social media we're you know essentially
putting highly addictive drugs into the
hands of kids before they have any
natural defenses against them and what
you're seeing with Internet addiction
with social media addiction with porn
addiction it's the same thing over and
over it people trying to change their
state of consciousness
with a device trying to get at the
underlying neural chemical chemistry and
it's very very addictive
[Music]